Experience.
I'm always trying to type faster than
that commercial and I always fail.
So I'm trying to tweet this live in the
moment and then stare at it.
My,
with my ever shittier eyes.
Oh yeah.
Tell me what am I supposed to tweet it?
I'm doing this right now.
I just tweeted it.
You could retweet it and that way it'll
be,
but I've tweeted,
my eyes are fine until I w I stare at my
fucking computer too much.
No,
they,
they get screwed up and then you try to
look at the TV and you can't see what's
going on.
It's guaranteed it's age,
but it's also,
I don't think screens are good for you.
Have you ever like taken a picture with
your cell phone of a screen and then you
see those lines that you can't say like
whatever the fuck those are.
Well let's actually just your phones,
the aperture on the camera's not able to
catch up with the flickering images
arise.
So then if I'm looking through this
screen at that,
that doesn't fuck with my eyes and think
it's the actual strain of staring at
something that's lit up so close to your
face that's really fucking with you more
than anything.
Isn't that correct?
Is that the correct aperture?
Is that the correct terminology?
And you're squinting or you're reading,
you're,
you're squinting your eyes.
You don't even realize it,
but that's not what we're talking about.
We're talking about the flashing thing.
The flashing thing like this,
just your camera can't catch shutter
speeds that what it is.
Um,
like if you watch a cars,
if you see videos of cars that have LCD
lenses,
there's something happens when you film
them,
it looks like they're flashing.
It's a different refresh rate usually.
Yeah.
It's weird.
I don't like any of that shit,
which is why my new special,
I actually did it in black and white
because I don't like HD TV.
I think it's,
I don't like seeing somebody pours is
they're talking to me like HD at this
point.
It was great.
And then it got to a point where it was
too,
it was too real.
It's clearer than real life.
Like I went to a game at a Dallas
Cowboys Football Stadium and they've got
this giant fucking TV classic Texas,
right?
We've got the biggest fucking TV,
you know,
that means we're the best and it was so
clear.
It looks realer than what was going on
in the field.
And you,
I had to like pull my at the visor down
on my,
my,
my head cause I kept wanting to look at
that.
Tony,
we're almost like right in front of me.
The promoter hook me up with these great
seats.
He's fucking right there and I'm looking
up further away than he is for me
looking up at this giant fucking TV.
It's also an instinct to look at
screens.
I see that a lot of the UFC people are,
their babies do it.
Everybody does.
It's an instinct to stare because it's
so captivating and we're used to staring
at screens.
So like if you're at a sporting event
and there's a screen there,
you just autumn automatically start
gravitating towards that screen for
some,
I look at the screens here,
I usually always just look right here
instead of looking right there.
Well you should,
you're actually running shit as supposed
to do that and make sure that nothing's,
I don't know,
demons behind us and we don't know
about,
yeah,
I'm not a fan of a technology
electronics.
I liked some of it.
It just,
I feel like all the benefits of it are
taken away.
And then some with the crashing,
with the refreshing,
with the,
what the fuck just happened with the,
Oh,
now this is outdated and I have to buy a
new one and then I throw this one into
the fucking ocean.
I go back and forth.
I love it in a lot of ways because,
um,
I'm just fascinated by innovation.
I'm fascinated by these new things that
these new people keep inventing,
but there's also part of me that
realizes that a certain point,
Tom's not benefiting us anymore.
It's not like making our lives easier,
it's just making things more connected
to electronics.
It's making you more into like whatever
world to the electronics create.
Yeah.
Somewhere in the 90s we pretty much
could have slat towed here we will fine
and even people say,
well what about medical stuff and like
helping people out and everything,
helping them live long and cure disease
and everything.
That basically kills the rest of us to
keep that other person alive and then
they're still alive,
taken a shit that ends up in a river and
it just keeps polluting more and more.
We're just,
we're like,
we've just for all over the fucking
place and it really needs to shrink
down.
Like the technology I don't think would
be a problem if they weren't.
So everybody has a fucking lapped are so
many people have laptops and shirts and
all this shit that we just keep buying
and then throw it out.
Like you know that Paul put litter in
its place.
You ever think about that?
It's like when they pick it up,
where do you think it goes?
Do you think it leaves earth?
It just goes somewhere else.
We don't have to look at it and it's
just fucking sitting there.
What's going to happen is they're going
to figure out a way to take everything
that we make and turn it into either a
product or turn it into fuel.
Like whenever we make something and we
have to throw it out,
it'll just become fuel for something
else.
Do you know how many people would have
to agree just to even get that ball even
slightly moving?
They will just,
somehow Jesus would be brought up and
somehow,
uh,
just something them versus us,
Republican,
Democrat,
liberal,
conservative and nothing would get done
and they would just sit there screaming
at each other maybe.
Or maybe they could figure out a way to
actually use whatever the fuck pollution
is,
like whatever the carbon goes into the
atmosphere,
pull that out and convert that into
energy.
It seems like there's probably some
fucking nerds that already know how to
do something along those lines.
Maybe not to that level,
but at least take the shit from down the
dump.
You know,
they know how to do it.
There's just no money in it and it's
just like they probably get checks to
not get things done.
Please show up with hookers and fucking
just a fucking big freight train full of
money.
Kalon boys.
It's a party so that then we got to get
all new machines that's going to cost us
a bunch of money.
Just do it the way we do it until we die
and then you guys can do it how you want
to do it.
By then someone else has bought into the
deal.
So I am completely pessimistic when it
comes to that shit.
People think that that's all bullshit
that like those kinds of conspiracies
don't exist.
Come on,
you guys are just nuts.
This is stupid.
Nobody would do that.
If they get rid of pollution,
they would.
But if getting rid of the pollution
costs somebody money,
I guarantee you there'd be somebody that
tried to cock
pocket.
Yeah,
there would be.
If there was a guy like the,
the classic William Randolph Hearst
story,
I don't know this,
but the reason why marijuana became
illegal wasn't because there was a
problem with people smoking marijuana.
It was because William Randolph Hearst
owned paper mills and he also own
newspapers and so he was going to have
to convert his paper mills over the hemp
paper because it's way easier to grow.
You refill an entire forest in like a
year,
like you chop them down.
They brought her,
oh yeah.
I mean he owned a lot of newspapers and
he was the reason why Rosebud was,
you know,
that whole,
that whole citizen Kane movie,
the coast,
he's fucking,
he was fucking crazy.
But he had so much money and so much
power that he could just print fake
stories.
So he wrote these stories about blacks
and Mexicans and I'm sure he didn't
write them,
but he commissioned them blacks and
Michigan smoking this new drug called
marijuana and having sex with all these
white women.
Like that wasn't even what they called
marijuana.
If he actually did that.
I want to have people died because of
that story.
Oh God.
A lot.
I'm sure a lot people in jail.
I mean,
just think about that.
That was in the 1930s and it's still
stuck.
It was all about hemp.
It wasn't even about marijuana.
They weren't even worried about the
drug.
The drug was commonly used amongst jazz
singers and all these other people.
It's smoked pot.
It was a normal thing.
The real issue was the hemp,
like the commodity,
the non psychoactive hemp.
They were worried about it taking over
and having to spend millions of dollars
to convert all his paper plants to hemp
paper.
Yeah.
You just want to smoke weed
against the good spirits.
People who don't believe in conspiracy
is fighting to be.
It's like,
dude,
you can inspire.
You go to a bar,
you see two hot chicks.
She come up with a game plan.
That's a conspiracy.
You conspiring to get over there and try
and fuck them.
Then just to sit there and like,
like all advertising there.
You're a cunt.
What the fuck I'm doing here now?
Selling my special.
You don't conspire.
Yeah.
You think I just showed up here?
We conspired talks.
Your children's got a Zillion fucking
followers.
He's a fan of my shit.
I know it's gonna come off.
Good.
This'll get me more like,
yeah,
I want,
I want this to keep going.
Just not randomly doing this shit.
You're conspiring.
Yeah.
But just because I'm not whacking a
president in the middle of it doesn't
mean it's not a conspiracy.
Well,
the shed like the end
Ron's disaster that went down,
that was a conspiracy.
There's a bunch of conspiracies that you
could see in clear form
that actually did happen.
Well,
the best thing they did is they make
conspiracy synonymous with more ronic
thought.
And everybody says,
Oh,
you putting your 10 ad on.
It's like this whole country came about
through a conspiracy.
The Revolution was not a spontaneous
act.
People sat there and was like,
okay,
we're going to rebel against these
fuckers.
Well,
they're gonna hang us as traders if we
don't pull this off.
They came up with a game plan,
if you want to call it that.
But if,
if they lost,
they would,
they would have been talking about this
treasonous conspiracy by all these guys
that are now on our money site.
Right up.
So true.
That's so true.
Yeah.
But now,
but then if you say you're into any sort
of conspiracy,
that automatically means you think nine
11 was an inside job and that the moon
was made out of cheese.
Well nine 11 is the best one because
this is the one that I was using.
My favorite one.
When people don't believe in
conspiracies,
I just say,
do you believe that nine 11 happened?
And they say yes.
Well then you believe in conspiracies
cause people conspired to fucking hijack
planes and fly them in a buildings that
doesn't just by my whole thing was that,
that you know that Americans were
involved.
And then that image,
give me a fucking break.
Okay,
right on it.
Right out the gate.
You gotta be like,
okay,
so who wants to fly it in and die
there?
God likes to do,
I mean you got to have an absolute
fucking nutjob do something like that.
So do you got to have them?
I mean,
I don't think we've ever even,
we've never had kamikaze is you now have
been able to get Americans to be like,
listen,
I'll go over there and try and fuck some
people up,
but if you think I'm going to fly some
shit into something or walk into a cafe,
strapped up with a bomb the fuck outta
here,
no Americans to Dadada,
we've had guys jump on grenades to save
other people to run into pizza hut.
And that's not our style.
That's not,
that's not our style.
We're not in a suicide bombing.
Yeah,
we're in to doing it from 60,000 feet,
calling it freedom with an x box.
No.
The funny thing about the original
suicide bombers,
the,
uh,
the kamikaze says there were all mapped
out.
I didn't realize that until a few years
ago.
I didn't even know that math was like an
important part of their diet back then.
I never saw that in the Ken Burns
documentary.
It's apparently of just a historical
fact.
And even there was a recent report on
Hitler.
Hitler himself was on,
uh,
a litany of medication and one of them
was meth.
They were giving a meth.
They would give meth to people,
but I can't fault him for that dude.
The amount of energy that that guy put
out during his speeches,
he needed something to level off.
Forget about,
forget about the screaming and yelling.
Just sitting that still
waiting for the right moment.
Building them into that.
That frenzy.
Do you ever watch that Michael Jackson
documentary right before he died,
when he drove,
just freeze after he did a dance move.
Let it simmer.
That's Hitler Shit.
Just sitting in that fucking chair.
Just getting him crazy.
Just wanting to hear or see the next
thing.
What's he gonna do?
It's timing.
It's fucking timing.
Some people do that on stage.
The Michael Jackson Hitler simmer
moment.
You would have to,
we got to do that tonight at the comedy
store.
All right,
we good?
Okay.
We've got to have this.
You got him.
Oh Dude.
If we had some of the technology,
I could be in your ear telling me keep
[inaudible].
You had to keep a straight face after a
punchline.
As you're looking down some fucked up
hose and I'm just going to let it
simmer,
let it simmer,
let it simmer and release.
So my dad was great.
Comedy clubs are filled with drugs and
it's nothing.
You know the thing about a guy like
Michael Jackson,
he's up there doing some shit you can't
do,
he spinning and moon walking and it's an
acrobatic event.
But you see a guy like you are a guy
like me on stage talking and you're
like,
I can fucking talk.
You know we all have to get a couple of
drinks.
Just kind of went out like we're going
to do roll call.
Yeah,
you have a couple of drinks.
I can fucking talk.
I know how to talk.
I can't moonwalk.
I could fuck a talk.
So you can't hold those,
those pauses to them.
It's like the green light fucking queer
that can help.
Right?
They can't help it.
Those big juicy pauses.
It's just this opening.
They could,
they could say something funny too,
like when it happens in a movie theater,
most of the time it's retarded.
But every now and then someone will yell
something out in a movie theater and
it's fucking hilarious.
Right.
And then that guy,
you know,
he becomes a hero for that crowd.
He just killed.
There's always that one guy doing the
sporting event.
So like now we'd like to take a moment
of silence for all the victims.
Yeah,
the fucking outhouse fire and everybody
shuts up and it's like,
just,
we just want you to remain quiet for 30
seconds.
It's always that guy.
20 seconds.
They just hear this guy go
like,
let's wrap it up.
I want to see what I came in to pay for.
Why do those fucking moments of silence?
Like she know you could do like a 10
count at a boxing match if a,
you know,
Lou Dibella dies or something like that.
Or one of those guys.
What was his name?
Lou was the,
the the famous guy that had like the
worst skin.
No,
no,
no.
There's this famous,
it's funny.
So I'm video flu,
Goddammit Wallach.
I don't remember the name I'll send her
was as new.
It's famous all throughout the grant.
1980s Easton's he used to train Meldrick
Taylor.
I don't remember.
Anyway,
the point is he looked like the most
unhealthy guy ever.
Who Do Va.
That's it.
Luke Duba.
You nailed it.
Pull up a picture of Lou do.
But just so everybody knows what the
fuck we're talking about.
But he was,
you know when he died,
I'm sure they had a a 10 count for a guy
like that.
A 10 count.
Okay.
But those fucking 30 seconds of silence.
Come on man.
He had to pay for that wonderful head of
hair,
man.
You have to see what this dude,
it looks like.
I don't remember what he page not found.
That's what they looked like.
He looked like an older Freddie Blassie
classy.
Freddie Blassie.
Nobody.
There he is.
Lil Duval.
Come on.
Seriously.
That might be the most unhealthy looking
man that's ever lived.
Yeah,
but that's right towards the end,
Matt,
even 12 he had that Elvis here.
He did have some good hair.
Did Fonzie here phrase whole fucking
life.
I'm so jealous.
Anyway,
point being those moments that you do in
like that kind of a performance.
And plus if Michael Jackson's doing it
this fucking 30,000 people there and you
know,
at least 68 huge numbers.
Yeah.
What was like the biggest place he's
ever done?
It was probably like hundreds of
thousands.
The original family that owned the New
England
patriots,
they went bankrupt on the Michael
Jackson victory tour when he went out
with a,
with all of his brothers,
uh,
the sun put the thing together,
and I don't know if this is true,
so I got to preface this,
but a promoter in Boston told me this
cold forever.
Like Michael Jackson was going to go to
Foxboro stadium with a patriots were
playing and they promoted the show and
all the tickets and he had that would of
pay or play,
whatever they call,
no matter what,
you got to pay the guy.
And the town of Foxborough said,
no,
we don't want to show,
we don't want all these black people
coming out here.
All right.
That's what it was.
I mean the white people got too crazy on
Monday night and they stopped having
Monday night football for like 20 years.
Like FoxPro was like,
then we're not having this really,
this is a quiet little town,
have you football game during the day on
Sunday and then get the fuck out of
here.
So they canceled the show and I thought
the,
the amount of money lost on that show,
they were close enough that that brought
him under.
But what this promoted was claiming was
this guy actually promoted the whole
tour.
And when he was doing the finances,
he didn't take into consideration how
big Michael Jackson stage was and how
many seats that that was going to eat
up.
He had this giant ass fucking stage that
was eating up like tens of thousands of
dollars a night times all of these
fucking dates.
And when he tried to get him go,
Hey Mike,
can you just have a smaller stage,
blah blah.
I guess he was competing with Prince and
was saying like now cause if I have a
smallest stage,
prince will have a bigger stage and I
got to make sure my shit is bigger than
his.
Of course you said that in a falsetto,
I don't know if this is true.
Right.
But like this is the story of this guy
told me,
it blew my mind.
I was like Oh I always thought they went
broke on just on one fucking date that
he canceled that and I just figured you
know there's 60,000 people there.
That's what reminded me talking about
60,000 people all paid that money and he
still had to give him a cut of that and
they just didn't have it.
That actually does make sense that the
the size of the stage thing.
That totally makes sense.
Yeah.
Cause there's a comedy club that did
that in New York where they,
for some reason they moved the stage out
away from the wall and now this little
small club and they moved it away from
the wall so the waitresses could walk
behind the stage behind this wall.
And like they took out like five or six
tables and all the other comedy clubs
were laughing and they figured out how
much money they fucked themselves out of
over the course of a year.
You know,
doing shows two or three shows a night
times six,
seven days.
Like they were fucking themselves out of
like three quarters of a million dollars
a year.
So they hadn't,
they,
they ended up having to move the wall.
Those fucking hilarious,
everybody from day one is just like,
this is stupid.
It was already one of those rooms that
was kind of shape.
It's not to celebrate was shaped like
the seller where it's like you're
standing sideways in a rectangle.
So you kinda got to angle yourself and
they took that shit and moved you
further into the crowd.
So it was almost like a year in the
round almost.
Yeah,
but only on,
but the people who are at two sides,
this is a place like that in San
Francisco.
There's a theater that I did.
It's like that.
It's weird.
You walk the stage goes out into the
crowd and like,
so people are behind you.
And to the left and behind you and to
the right.
It's very strange.
You did that thing with me,
right?
Yeah.
That was weird.
Right.
I know that you have,
I want to be sitting behind a
performance.
No,
well I'm doing a theater in the round
in,
in Phoenix.
Just collaborative theater.
Yeah.
Just cause it would be weird now that I
do it five times before you do,
Oh,
you've done this before.
I just start the joke on this side and
then turn an end on that side and I just
really try to be conscious of sections.
Like Dane said,
the most brilliant thing about the,
uh,
the,
the theater in the round,
he goes,
it's for theaters.
Just look at it that way.
It's four theaters just all stuck
together and you just sorta performing
one theater.
Then this one and then that went over
there and then I just think you do it
like the,
the,
the three card Monte,
he just sort of switch it up like you
don't,
right,
right.
As you go around.
But I know,
I know people that have seen comics I'll
do is theater in the round.
They'll be like,
so and so was here and he didn't move
it.
Not One of those comics,
it's just standing with the mic and the
mic stand.
So they were in the back and just
sitting there and one of them had like a
slow turning stage.
So eventually you just send that dude 20
more jokes.
He's going to be looking at us.
So he made the stage turn while they
have a stage that turns.
And I think that's for musical acts.
We have a drama drunk kid in amps
planted,
so they're not moving,
but it's also for,
I think like performance who just want
to stand there and not move around.
It's fun around like they're wrote a
fucking carousel.
You did that one very slowly.
Very slowly.
It spins around the one that turns
though.
Yeah.
But it turns very slowly.
Very slowly.
It's the same place.
Yeah.
The celebrity theater.
That's the one we're talking about.
Yeah.
I forgot that it turns.
Yeah,
they asked me the option,
do you want the stage turned on?
Um,
I'm definitely gonna say yes.
Oh,
I always say no.
It's like I don't need,
I don't need that.
I want to just for,
cause it's weird.
Yeah.
Well if they can speed it up,
you could literally just be running in
place doing a whole fucking choke
running against it.
My goal is to do so many shots while
months,
days that I can't figure out where the
stool is at any given time.
It can be anywhere.
It's moving around.
No.
Well I was going to say,
no way.
I've been drunk twice on stage.
It was twice,
twice and 20 something years.
Yeah.
It's not the best move every now and
then though.
It's the right thing to do once I was in
Ireland.
So that's not my fault.
And the other time I was coming back
from a Yankees Red Sox game and didn't
know it was going to have a show and
somebody called up,
hey,
I had a falling out,
can you come down and do the show?
And I thought it was sober.
One of those like,
yeah,
Hey,
I'll do it.
And I just went up there and I was just
like,
she's,
yeah,
should I heard?
And I was just like,
oh shit.
I had to slow way down and had a very,
very uh,
subpar fucking shows bad.
So you had a slow way down just to get
your mouth to work right?
Yes.
Which killed the timing of everything.
So I,
I bombed very slowly.
I see that with um,
that the term punch drunk.
That's like a term that people don't
like.
But that's a,
that's exactly what it's like.
That same thing where you know you're a
little fucked up so you have to struggle
to get your words out.
But you could see that in fighters it's
exact same thing.
It's why they call it punch drunk.
It's not just,
they sound like they're drunk,
but the same thing like you have to
struggle
to control your situation and then when
those guys get drunk,
that's when you see guys that are really
punched drunk guys that had been punched
drunk get drunk.
Cause then you see they have a hard side
because they have a really hard time
controlling the words then that it's
just a,
it's a mangled mess.
It's hard to understand the,
that
that UFC,
the a,
what do you call when they stick them in
the house and all that shit.
Ultimate fighter,
the ultimate fighter and it's all women.
And like I remember last time I did your
podcast,
I was against it like women in the
octagon.
It's like they,
they like why would you do that?
They're beautiful.
Why would you punch each other in the
face?
And I want to see a jab.
Do you have breasts and shed?
It's just,
I didn't want to see it and now I don't
even notice it anymore.
And it's,
it's unbelievably fucking entertaining.
You don't notice that the girls anymore.
Now I know they're great fights and it's
guys who are already good at talking
shit and fucking not liking each other,
but they're just women.
Just take it to that extra fucking
level,
that shit talking.
And then the fact that they can beat the
fuck out of you.
And then it's funny there's a guy to be
just watching it going like there is not
one woman in this house that I could
even get on the floor.
Like these women would all just mop the
floor with me.
There's a fucking hilarious youtube
video.
Somebody tweeted it to me and I don't,
I don't know,
I just lost it in the ether.
It was this girl,
it just starts writing in.
It was almost one of those six second
videos,
whatever the fucking kids call him.
And you knew this kid had a little bit
of training and this girl had more
training and she came at him and it was
like she climbed up his body,
like stepped on his fucking thigh and
then was behind them.
And the video ends with him just
grabbing like,
this is its rear naked girl.
You know,
he was out before he went and the whole
Party just goes,
oh,
and it ends and I fucking died laughing.
But going like I wouldn't even have
lasted as long is that kid did.
Cause it seemed like he knew a little
bit of a defense.
A little bit of defense like I have a
great Rhonda Rousey.
Bit of like what it would be like to
date her if she was actually physically
abusive,
but I just can't do the prat fall.
I want to act like you know her big
movies.
She does that fucking throw and you go
over a hip and just you fucking landed
on the ground.
You're like in a relationship with her.
Oh our bar real mature.
Showing you like I know I tapped out.
That doesn't mean because you're right.
I didn't want my heart broken and then
she comes out.
You got to knock down the stool to try
to have something in between you and
her.
I think it took like that probably has
to date a fighter.
If I had to guess.
She probably has to date some guy who
also knows how to do what she does.
I just couldn't imagine
Jen a fight data.
I'd be on the kitchen like an apron just
like make her an her food and shit.
I just couldn't get me.
Look at me sideways.
You'd fuck me up.
Almost every female fighter does.
They all date fighters.
They just does.
Just seems like,
you know a girl being in a position like
that where she could just beat the fuck
out of her boyfriend.
I don't think chicks like that.
That's,
I never looked at it that way cause I
always thought it was hilarious.
Like I,
I,
I could date somebody like that.
I would think it was funny that they can
kick the shit and one of my guy friends
gave me shit.
I'd be like,
yeah man,
she kicked shit out of me.
And you,
I think it's funny but like I never
looked at it like,
cause even though they are like,
like these lethal weapons now there is
still there could possibly still I
should say,
I don't want to speak for him that this
female male relationship where that they
still want the guy to be able to protect
them and it's just kind of like uh yeah
dude that's funny.
Cause then they're just sort of
rendering you useless cause they're
already making a zillion dollars.
So there goes your on providing I can
protect you and do what I can kick your
ass.
And then I can also have a kid.
So you're basically now like a 45 year
old teenager,
which just gives you a little height
chair.
You know what I like about watching it?
Like self sustained unit?
I think it's fucking awesome.
What I like about watching female fights
is the,
they're more reliant on technique
because they don't have overwhelming
physical strength,
but there are certain guys that have
overwhelming physical strength and
abilities you can plow through.
Yeah.
They could just defects in that game.
Yeah,
they can muscle things.
They can,
they just hit really hard.
So sometimes they have like shitty
technique.
They throw windmill punches,
but with a lot of women,
what you're getting is you're getting
the purest technique.
You can,
again,
it
depends on where you're head is a
gentleman with my opponent given plenty
of time to see it coming
and let them know the couches are always
coming from the same direction.
If he see the left,
the next one's the right.
Have you see the right?
The next one?
Yeah.
Don't get tricky.
What's fucking dumb?
You're less linear story.
This isn't Tarantino.
We're dancing here.
Okay.
Left right,
left,
right.
But with checks,
they're,
they're forced to use more tech mean the
obviously there's,
there's a curve as far as like physical
strength is like someone like Serena
Williams.
So obviously a very physically strong
girl and there's other girls that are
like not as physically strong,
you know,
throw me over a couch and you know,
when you hit the window like sideways
and then slide that she's so land on
some gym shoes pressive like her legs
and the strength that she has,
I was at,
I was at a party one time,
uh,
some agency I used to be at and they
also represented her and you forget your
agency also represents,
you know,
athletes cause they want to like
fucking,
you know,
make money off of selling to readers or
whatever.
Right.
And she was at the party with a
basketball player,
so he was like,
you know,
so they were probably a portion couple,
like I felt like a dwarf dude.
Like she was like,
uh,
just like,
it was totally gorgeous.
Totally in proportion,
just like,
like super athlete.
Do Marvel Comic,
uh,
bodies that's like on like,
dude,
you should be wearing a fucking cape.
It just,
no,
and it's just,
you know,
you just see people like that and you
just go like,
oh yeah,
that's why like you always sit there in
the back of your head as you watching
some quarterback.
That sucks.
What if I did some more setups?
What if I get thrown against my body
like fucking Brett far,
but not throw an interception.
And then you actually run into the real
athletes do.
When I saw Joe Theismann who always
looked like a little fella,
you know,
when he was out there,
he had the one little bar here,
he got his leg broken.
He just,
he always looked just so small.
When he was out there,
I saw the guy and like in a mall,
he's like six one in like still jacked.
I'm like almost five,
10.
I'm just going like,
this guy would fucking drop me.
How did he,
uh,
did he get his leg fixed to,
they put bars in it and pins and shit.
Like how did he get his legs fixed?
I imagine I haven't been in contact with
the,
did anybody at the hospital,
did that end his career?
That was my,
my question.
Yes it did.
That was the last play he watched.
He said,
I'm on what time you said he watched the
replay one time.
Uh,
and that was,
that was it for him and uh,
and I actually win a silver,
broke his leg.
I think that reminded me of that,
that compound fracture of just like,
oh my God.
Oh my God,
I can't even imagine the pain.
And then going into the shock.
And then the fact now is he's coming
back,
right Silva's.
Yeah.
January is to fucking sit there after
you went through that and to just the
first time you start throwing kicks with
that leg again.
Just like the level of whatever that is.
I don't have that anywhere in my life.
Like if I ever fucking broke my leg like
that doing stand up,
that's it.
I would,
I would be,
I'd open a comedy club used to go up on
stage.
I know I don't,
I don't want to do that anymore.
He's at the end of his career.
He's got a few years left fighting and
uh,
he has an opportunity to still make a
lot of money and I think he's probably
just going to make as much money as you
can over the next few years and then get
out.
Now what,
what is the,
that that rumor that I hear that if you
break a bone,
this is such a bother heal stronger and
heal stronger to sort of,
I mean it's less likely to break in the
area where it broke.
It's less likely to break there.
It gets knotted up and thick,
but not necessarily sure it gets
stronger.
Thank you doctor Brogan and say,
why am I asking you these fucking
questions?
Do know a lot about broken bones.
This is how I learned all of my shit.
Asking people who don't have the job,
asking ups,
get all those packages to everybody
overnight.
If you ever have questions like that and
you want answers,
ask Brian Cowen and even if he doesn't
know the answer,
he'll fucking keep going.
He will come up with something that's a
logical just insecurity of just not
knowing the answer.
He just has to fucking answer.
He'll fuck it.
Argue about some shit.
He's not educated at all
I love,
but he also has a shitload of fucking
information is had.
Brian is like one of the best I've ever
right.
Met At being able to pull quotes out of
the air about books that he's read like
constantly.
He's writing book hang with him from
one,
three minutes.
You realize he's out of his fucking
mind.
He's crazy.
He just gets the best everything.
I love him.
I love him,
but he's out.
He's out of his fucking mind.
There's definitely crazy.
He's fucking mind is going like a
thousand rpms constantly.
Whenever I talked to him.
You just got to do the alley.
You lay against the ropes and just let
all the information come at you and then
you get them with one and then you come
back.
Oh,
and by the way we can do it.
He got a pair of shoulders on you.
How would he to do at that point?
Is that what is hanging off of,
you know,
I bet you got to be sign.
Yeah.
And a piece on Ya.
I went hunting with him.
It was five.
I mean I've done it three times now.
It's five days of gay jokes.
Fish by not shutting up.
You really should be here.
People are gonna think I don't like him.
I love him.
I just like trashing him.
He knows what he does.
That's part of his charm is that he
likes to make fun of himself.
Did he go out and talk to the bear and
ask him what he's doing to get those
back muscles?
He would
almost as big as mine.
I got mad.
I got to find out.
But we were for five days.
If I walked around on all fours and
occasionally stood up,
I like a beer.
I'd be like a bear without all that
hair.
Five days,
every time.
It's just constantly the Brian Count
show cause you could just wind them up.
He's just that guy.
He's always on.
He's never not funny.
Like he's never,
I never called Bryon.
He's depressed,
you know.
If he is depressed and be depressed for
a couple of minutes and then it'll just
start talking about something and it'll
tell you start talking about lean muscle
mass or how he's built for dance and
he'll just go into something and then
next thing you know you're laughing.
He just doesn't want that uncomfortable
silence.
No.
He's like,
what's his face at the end of the hulk?
Feel big speed instead of walking away
from the town.
Those were his troubles.
Do you know that the hulk,
they changed.
I just want to keep trashing him until
people show them this clip.
Two I get on his show again.
They changed the hoax name by the way,
the piece of salt now that's from uh,
the,
the hippie warehouse.
These ideas,
the salt crystal lamps,
they're supposed to and somehow or
another like generate positive ions and
Salsify,
the air float through the air and make
you feel better.
They changed.
Robert Banner was a bill Bixby
characters name on the hulk,
but the real,
the real name is Bruce Banner.
Right.
But they changed it from Bruce to Robert
for TV because they thought Bruce is a
gaining Bruce.
How did it bro?
You angry again?
I'll get mad.
Right?
God Green last night it was don thing
and you ruined your pants again.
Bruce become a gaming.
It's like Bruce for the long.
For the longest time it was like,
you know Bruce,
I was going to say Bruce Jenner,
but I guess that's a bad example now.
It was a good example a few years back
to that guy.
What's going on?
He's such a good looking guy.
Yeah,
no,
it was never anything wrong with his
nose.
He's becoming a good looking older lady
though.
That's what's going on.
Hey,
God bless them.
If it makes him happy,
God bless him.
I just,
I just don't.
Just watching people fucking age badly.
Oh,
attack in their face.
Yeah.
It's a weird thing that people do.
They get,
they want to change it and then they
think when they changed that it looks
better.
It just looks different for the most
part.
How much of a hug do you need if you're
staring at your throat in the mirror,
like sideways holding America.
And I don't like my Adam's apple,
like I don't think I've,
I don't know what my Adam's apple look,
I couldn't pick up my Adam's apple and a
fucking lineup.
I don't think I've ever looked at it.
I think his deal,
and I'm just guessing is that he's
probably transitioning to being a woman.
If I had to guess.
I think,
I think that's a probably a pretty safe
estimate at this point.
He's grown his hair long.
His nails are long.
He had is now,
do you think he'll come back [inaudible]
name or do you think he'll just got
fingernail Polish on now?
Man.
Do you think he'll,
he'll uh,
he'll,
he'll go with a,
um,
a new name,
like three Cema.
Yes.
I'm saying,
do you think he'll go hacky and just
make his name of feminine like Bill,
Bill Arena?
Like Betty has a fucking full character
that he,
that he becomes when it becomes,
let me see,
let me put,
bring it back up.
Bring it back up.
Those nails.
I mean,
first of all,
if this is fake,
he looks like a Jennifer.
You think so?
I would say Claudia.
Nah,
he's not a Claudia.
I was going to say he looks like a
Claudia.
Look at him.
He's got a cigarette.
Susan or a Jennifer.
So he's smoking cigarettes to
look at him right here.
Yeah.
We all know gay people.
They're always smoking cigarettes.
That's what is happening.
I think that looks like that's a pretty
good picture of what he probably looks
like.
He has like his lipstick on when no
one's looking and he's tucking.
That's bad.
He looks like he looks like an older
lead singer of a band and they're doing
the casino circuit.
The earrings too.
It's like he really,
he seems to be coming.
A woman seems to be becoming one good
for him.
Yeah.
I mean this is a good time to be a lady
is a good time to be a transgender woman
to,
you know,
people are more accepting of it than
ever before.
It's a good time for me,
but it's,
I mean
it should,
but it should bother you.
It should not really.
Should not.
It should not.
You know,
having said that,
I hate the color of his nail Polish.
The red is my favorite.
I feel like if you're going to fail,
he's that he's that type that's too racy
for,
I don't mind it.
He's an Olympic medalist.
What do you think you should have black
go golf.
I think he needs an edge.
I think he's just a little too soft.
Like God's got his hair blown out.
I wouldn't,
if I had to do a makeover,
less scarves,
less flowing shit.
And I,
yeah,
he needs an edge man.
Poor God.
Look at him.
He's wearing those visors,
this old lady tennis visors.
If you're not a hunter s Thompson and
they don't say that Vegas on them.
Take that fucking thing off.
That was the picture of absolute bliss
though.
I think he wants to do it.
That's what he wants to do.
Well listen,
he's been with those crazy bitches for
so long.
He became one.
I mean,
that's really what it is.
I think it's a little more,
I think they tricked him.
Joe.
I think they could put you in that
house.
And I don't think you're coming out
looking like that.
I probably would imagine if,
I did imagine if it was proven that if
you're around women like that many women
long enough,
they slowly but surely Ab your
masculinity away.
Do you want to become a woman?
Okay.
If it's proven that like we,
we imitate our atmosphere so much that
one more around the opposite sex for two
months or one of those people that view
a,
what's that psychological word?
They say that you're a,
a,
you're codependent and you know,
you got to watch out who you hang out
with.
They're pretty soon you're doing what
they're doing and next thing you know,
you know there are people like you want
a pleated skirt,
you'd like some uggs probably starts
with the eggs.
I think it starts to feet it the feet
first head of curious and then you,
your work your way up your body if
you're easing into it.
Yeah,
because people aren't going to notice
that
time.
One time I got a manicure,
I fucking hated it.
Did you get angry?
No,
I just,
I didn't like it.
Pain.
I didn't.
Why didn't you like it?
Well,
I was on,
I was on the road with the,
uh,
Charlie Murphy and Don l and it's
acceptable in the,
uh,
amongst black guys to get your fucking
nails done.
Right.
It's like considered some pimp shit.
So like you got to do it.
So I've literally sitting there,
okay,
next Charlie like this with my hand in
the thing and I'm lab bill Byrd is the
way to do it.
No,
he was laughing too because I just kept
saying,
this is the most feminist fucking thing
I've ever done.
Forget about doing it with you who's
just overloaded with testosterone.
Say,
Charlie,
you need to do this so you don't win.
Mill kicked somebody.
I don't know.
I'm more in the middle.
I don't need to do this.
And I was on stage that night and I was
just going like this.
I was self conscious.
I got the,
I got the clear,
I got the clear fetish and they were
just like,
glistening.
Yeah.
But then what sucks is then it starts to
peel.
So then he just,
he had just fucking scratch and then it
looks gross.
Did you try to prematurely age it?
Do you like maybe get some sandpaper and
rubber?
I was doing all,
I was super homophobic about it.
Fingers in the dirt.
Like fisting the dirt.
Yeah.
Trying to get the nail Polish off now I
found somebody with one of those gravel
driveways isn't a fun thing in the
African American community getting your
toes and nails done.
Like this picture's a dude's like
getting their toes done on the cell
phone.
No talking Aubrey with this Alpha now I
remember that.
Yeah.
No it wasn't really his was his friend's
company,
but yeah,
he was a part of it.
Yeah.
No they,
they,
they take being cleaned to a whole
nother level and is generally speaking,
some of 'em think white people are
pretty filthy.
That was a trend in MMA fighters for the
longest time was getting their nails
done.
Like chocolate.
Dell started out [inaudible] is funny,
man colored pink and I thought it was to
me,
that's fucking funny cause you can kick
the shit out of somebody.
That's that.
Yeah.
Way that Bruce Lee story.
What's stuff that he used to walk around
wherever the fuck he was from even go
into the city and he would act all the
feminine so people would fuck with them
and then he'd beat the shit
out of him and his friend would say,
why did you do that?
And he said,
because if I just kicked his ass,
he could get over it.
But if some of feminine guy kicked his
ass,
that's going to stay with them.
And I want that to be true.
I can give you the,
the whatever the book is.
The Bruce Lee book is a,
it has a red cover.
I can never remember the name of it and
a black and white photo and he's like
this and just fucking shredded.
Yeah,
he was across to all the other Bruce Lee
photos where he's like 20 pounds
overweight.
Sorry.
I would think that he would probably be
a guy who would come up with a bunch of
different real life scenarios just to
test as martial arts and to,
to,
you know,
becoming a feminine guy and have guys
try to beat your ass.
It seems like a good move.
It's pretty bad ass.
I think it's a smart move because most
people spend their lives right here.
Avoiding physical confrontations.
It's like,
you know,
you know once,
once people really started gaining
weight and fucking bloody noses and
broke,
busted eye sockets,
I tapped out.
I was just like,
I'm going to tell some jokes.
If you,
the only way to really test it is to
test in a real life situation.
There's a lot of people that look really
good in the gym and then when it comes
to an actual fight,
they just fall apart and panic.
They just can't do it.
I just think that you need that.
You got to have a couple of days that's
like,
you know,
for some drinks,
no,
you gotta,
you gotta have a couple of fights and
hopefully survive them.
Yeah.
If you don't have a fight,
and if you ever,
you ever seen someone get in a fight
that's never been in a fight before and
go into a full panic?
No.
I think I've told this story before,
but it was at the comedy store.
We're sitting on the patio and there was
this guy,
this black guy in a white guy,
they were fighting in front of the House
of Blues and the yelling at each other
and it turns physical and as it turns
physical,
the white guy is in full on fucking
panic mode.
His eyes are closed and he's literally,
was this me flailing this way?
Like this way,
like not moving his shoulders,
but his arms are like,
like he's boxing the guy's ears.
That's what he's doing right.
Left,
right,
left.
I mean his hands are open.
He's just absolutely in a full panic.
And then a bus pulls in front of them
and then I don't get to see what the
fuck happened.
The bus moves past,
the guys laid out flat out called the
black guy's nowhere to be found.
The white guys fucking dead,
stiff,
knocked out.
People are freaking out.
So obviously he got hit.
I have no idea what happened.
Is this bad?
That's a bad,
that's not your face,
right?
Terrible technique.
It doesn't hurt your opponent.
Double Time.
It's the good thing about it is you
being very ethical,
like you're not,
you know,
harming your opponent.
You're involved in a physical
altercation but you're not going to do
any damage.
Just want to say is you don't wanna hurt
your hands punching somebody skull or
you don't want to fuck up your manicure.
Snoop Dogg Snoop Dogg has his nails did.
Wow.
He's gets French tips I guess.
Different colors.
White,
black,
white,
black.
Yeah.
Okay.
He's snoop Dogg.
He can do it.
Remember when Tate used to do his nails?
Tate used to have colored nails.
That whole Alpha Nail Polish thing.
Those,
there's a lot of dummies that we're
doing that for awhile they all got off
of it.
Roger worked had,
yeah.
That's
the type of shit that like when you
almost start dressing like a chick,
like you actually get more pussy.
Like more women come out.
Like that rock star thing,
that Androgynous fucking look.
You stop borrowing that close and next
thing you know that blowing you.
That's how I heard it went down.
What's really funny is that and hit
parade is pre like Reddit,
like Judas priest started a lot of the
metal stuff.
Rob Halford,
you know all the SLM dressing s and m
dressing and people didn't realize he
was gay as fuck.
Right?
Yeah.
I had no idea rob Hoffman was gay as
fuck and he got all of these guys to
essentially dress like gay s and m guys.
Yeah.
Like that was what became the luck is
brilliant,
but that's so much of a bad
motherfucker.
He is.
He made people kind of
one of the great front man and then
nothing too he,
he basically was completely 100% other
than Freddie Mercury,
who was literally in a band called Queen
and we're just so dumb.
Like,
no,
he's fine.
He's straight.
He sings good.
That's all.
Don't be homophobic
like it matters.
Yeah.
I have to ta do funny.
Mark,
you and me,
that fucking guy that live aid set is
one of the,
I would put that up against anybody's
performance ever.
Oh,
he was a bad mother fucker,
dude.
He turned Wembley Stadium into a fucking
coffee house.
He had them.
Everybody like the fucking back row that
had,
that guy was unbelievable.
He was sensational.
He was a really unique talent.
Like,
like there was no one like him before
because he was such a combination of
like masculinity and femininity and exp.
I never noticed any of that.
I was just like,
this fucking guy.
You can't stop watching him and his,
his,
uh,
his singing was incredible and he was
better live as good as the albums
worries.
One of the few guys that was actually
fucking better live.
I haven't seen anybody come close to
that guy.
Wow.
Since,
wow,
that's a strong,
anybody you got anybody that could fuck
fucking hold 100,000 people in the palm
of his hand after he had to follow all
those other beasts.
You know,
it's true.
You had to go and have to Robert Plant
Jimmy page.
I went,
didn't go well that was the one that was
one of the ones that didn't go out,
which is why 2007 went so well because
they were like,
we can't do that again.
They put it together the last fucking
second.
And then you had like say they had,
did they had to dramas at the sink.
Can you please whisper that in my ear
during my act and are
you were,
you were the first guy to call me up.
You called me up and left a message
about Zeplin you called me.
I'd be like,
you're not going to fucking believe
this,
but you got to go devastating.
Go on Youtube.
You're not going to fucking believe
this.
They stole everything.
They fucking stole away that I was
saying that they fucking,
this this thing they called the song
remains the same.
And they was showing how many dude there
right now going,
going to trial.
Yup.
On Stairway to heaven.
And you call me about this.
It was many years of dating to me.
I still love John Bottom.
I actually still loved that music
because I still have all cause it is
still great and I still,
and I,
all those childhood memories of where I
was when I,
when I was going on,
but like I,
you know,
it's like the Cosby thing.
He just hope it isn't true.
Well,
the Zeppelin thing to me.
Yeah.
With a riff raping women.
That latest one with the [inaudible]
worse.
Yeah.
The,
the,
the Cosby thing is very different
obviously.
But the thing about Zeppelin that got me
was that every band is influenced by
every other band,
every band.
I mean they all,
you're,
you're going back to everybody who your
fans with and this guys,
it's sound like guys because that was
their music and I think as a lot of us
has calming influence influenced,
no one ever got sued for my point though
is my point.
My point was,
but there's a certain line that you
cross that they crossed where they were
stealing rifts.
The opening to stairway to heaven.
It's like my God,
it's a silage they'll allege it seems
like the same thing.
Legit allegedly allegedly delivery.
But it made me less,
it made me like them less.
I know the music is still amazing,
but it made me like the less that was a,
that was devastating.
Yeah.
But they're still,
but I have a bootleg of this and they
have them at like
the whiskey or something and they have a
song called killing floor that sounds
like the lemon song.
And then by the time it's out on led
Zeppelin to,
it's called lemon song.
And then later they got sued for that by
the guy who wrote killing floor.
So they,
it's not like they didn't know.
That's one of those things where it's
just like,
dude,
you obviously knew that you were calling
a killing floor is a cover and then you
switched some of the lyrics and then
called it the lemon song.
That's fun.
But I don't know if this is,
to me,
this is just me,
is completely uneducated looking at this
shit.
I just know that,
uh,
you know,
that just is a little suspect.
But just,
you know,
obviously I'm not a musician,
so I mean,
I don't know.
Fucking,
I dunno.
I don't want it to be true.
I don't want it to be true either.
But that's the same thing as the Cosby
stuff.
Nobody wants,
I mean,
those,
I was reading this,
Chris Rock Article's really interesting,
Chris rock article where he's talking
about,
um,
people being offended by everything.
And that's why he doesn't do colleges
anymore cause it just looking to be
offended at things and they're just too
easy to offend.
But you know,
he was saying that he just doesn't want
it to be true.
And I think everybody feels like that
except the people that obviously were
raped by him.
Well,
they would want it not to be true
because then they wouldn't be raped.
Right.
So,
yeah.
So like all of like,
yeah,
you don't want that to happen to
somebody.
And then also this person that you,
you hold as a comedian,
you know,
we almost went to see him too.
We were going to,
we're planning on taking a trip to
Vegas.
I saw him earlier this year.
Did you?
Yup.
We're just seeing him.
I saw him out in Pasadena at a theater
and I met him,
uh,
about a year and a half ago.
It was fucking amazing.
Really.
It was amazing.
It was fucking amazing.
I was,
uh,
his set was amazing.
Yeah.
At everything.
When he went to go see the guy,
me talking about guy,
you know,
77 years,
76,
77 years old,
was excited about his new special and
was like,
why am I tell you I shot this Dang.
And then she was animated,
so fucking excited about his new special
and was just like to see a guy that far
into it still that excited about
standup.
Like,
dude,
like that gave me a charge for like
weeks and uh,
you know,
so like I said,
I hope it's not true.
Yeah.
I really hope it's not true for the
victims more so than it,
but you're just focusing on him though.
But if you're doing that,
then the victims are crazy lunches,
alleged victim.
Well,
I mean,
and then you know,
that's better to be a crazy person to be
a crazy liar than to be a rape victim.
They were to being raped by bill Cosby.
This new one is interesting because the
girl said it says she was 15 and he,
he took her to the playboy mansion and
allegedly,
but when you go to the playboy mansion,
they have your name on records.
Like every person that goes there has to
put their name down in all their
information down.
It's,
there might be actual proof that she was
15 and he took her to the playboy
mansion
sound like one of those bad news
programs.
So there might be,
we might have some information later on
so hang around for that.
But like not the little in the point
where,
but that's just his fucking brutal.
It's crazy though.
This all happened out of Hannibal
Burress his joke like him talking about
it on stage.
No,
somebody filming the person who put it
up should be getting credit cause Ha
Hannibal didn't do that and he shouldn't
be getting the grief either.
It was a fucking great joke is a funny
joke.
It's a joke.
Then it became funny bit possible fact.
Um,
I actually felt bad for him because I
don't think he wanted that.
I think he just,
I think it was just telling a joke.
They do it if some of this shit,
you know,
that's all of that shit is taken out of
car,
like re everything.
Like these fucking people who take your
shit.
They do the same thing that a news,
like a um,
a bias news channel or like a political
ad we'll do.
Like I did this rant making fun of cubs
fans versus White Sox fans.
And the reason why I did it was because
recently Chicago had beaten the Boston
team and all I wanted to do was cause
infighting.
Okay.
I didn't believe a fucking word of it.
And I,
and I went on this whole thing and then
I paused and in the end I said,
I'm just fucking with you guys.
I'm just mad because blah blah blah.
They lopped that part off and now it's
just a standalone piece that I'm
shitting all over cubs fans and I'm
defending white sox fans.
And then what was funny was I took a
wild guess and I actually,
people are like,
dude,
this is like fucking dead on.
This is exactly the way it is.
It's like I didn't know that but,
but the,
the point of it is is that they went up
there and they deliberately lopped off
the thing where I say it's just a joke.
So,
so there's that and I got a specialist
Friday man,
we really tried to fucking be interested
in that dumb story for the whole time.
You just,
all you had now we just went
to story bill.
I don't know where to go with that man.
No,
I'm thinking about this culture of
trying to catch people doing things like
that and I,
you know,
and get upset at them,
especially when it's clearly a joke and
I had a whole bit and in my act about
the difference between jokes that you
say on stage and like being in court and
getting fucking affidavit.
I have a whole bit in my last
special about lying.
I'm like,
I lie on stage all the time.
Like if you watch any of my act and you
go,
I don't,
I'm the,
I don't see things the way this guy,
I don't either.
I don't see these things in the way.
I see.
I'm talking about that around.
Yeah.
I'll say shit that I don't believe in.
If it's funny and that's,
I think part of what Chris Rock was
saying is that people are getting
offended.
Comics comics should apologize and less,
they actually meant it in a malicious
way that the person took it.
Like if you,
you know,
he can go on stage in a bad mood and you
can deliberately get an,
someone can heckle you or do something
and then you get mad and you
deliberately try to fucking piss him off
and uh,
you know,
you might owe somebody an apology then,
but you don't have to go on TV and
fucking apologize to the country.
People are doing it because they're
scared.
They don't want to lose the careers.
Then they also,
the people have demanded an apology.
You would have
in kind of say whatever you want.
That's not true.
You know,
you have a career,
so talking shit,
I understand that.
But the thing is,
as of yet,
I do not have a TV show.
Why don't you have to teach better off
without it.
That's when better off without the fuck
you doing to this animated show that I'm
doing comes out to you.
Wait,
you wait,
but you're doing great.
Stand up though.
Yeah,
I know.
I'm not saying,
I'm just saying,
but the animated thing was the perfect
way to go into the TV because you can
get away with anything.
Yeah.
Cause you can't,
you're not going to offend anybody with
these animated people.
Like what,
what message is this going to send to
animated children?
You know what I mean?
What about all the three fingered
fucking yellow headed people out there?
Are they going to,
what are they going to think that it
just piss off Asians.
Nobody got hurt.
No,
no headed.
As long as I like square heads thinking
Simpsons,
uh,
someone we'll lop would cut it off there
and just be like,
yeah,
what are you gonna do you,
you're always,
when you ever saying anything on stage
that's controversial,
you're always going to open yourself up
to opportunistic people that just want
click bait.
There's no such thing as controversy in,
in standup comedy.
There's no such thing.
It is.
It is manufactured controversy.
It's all complete horseshit.
It's one person in the crowd.
The amount of times that they've showed
clips of comics who said something
controversial.
You literally hear the crowd laughing on
the fucking tape.
Everybody's laughing.
Taking it as a joke and one fucking
person and then you know,
and then you just take it out of
context,
which is out of the comedy club.
I mean,
I'm trying to think of a joke.
Any of my jokes that I could do on the
news that wouldn't seem like,
you know,
I'm doing this bit about Isis and how
they're not a threat and I'd like to see
him try to invade Florida where
silencers are legal and see how far they
fucking get now.
That's silly and ridiculous and funny.
And a comedy club.
You then put that on Fox News.
Bill Burns says isis is not real.
Well what about the soldiers died?
We return the controversial tape we'll
be playing.
What about the soldiers that died?
We are here from Florida that actually
confronted Isis.
When we return,
he listens to what bill said.
And then after that show and Nancy
Grace,
we'll pick it up on the next hour.
Bill Baer,
the standup Comedienne.
You might have seen him on such shows as
breaking bad bad.
I'm going to go out on a limb and say
she's a hot shit.
If you went out and drag with the,
do you think so?
She would just laugh Vic.
Yeah.
It's a fucking shell.
Do you think she's just being,
well,
she was a print.
How much do you know how much my face
hurts to pretend to be that mad?
Every episode.
I love coming out here and smoking a
little weed and fucking get in a
relaxed.
My eyebrows.
I eat Twinkies.
I'll really,
I get foot massages.
No,
I think she would be fun as hell to hang
out with.
Andy actually get into an argument with,
it's just a,
she makes unfortunate faces on TV.
I think she's probably exactly like she
comes off on TV.
I bet that's her.
Uh,
Nah.
You can tell you right now.
You,
me and Nancy Grace driving to Vegas.
We wouldn't be laughing our fucking
asses off you and I would be laughing
our asses off,
but it'll probably get ugly with her.
I would buy the inland empire.
She would loosen up.
He thinks,
yeah,
we'd shut off our cell phones.
You're not being recorded.
Just fucking,
I was held hostage by profanity farts
out
show she did,
but she'd have a good time over.
They irritate me for four hours now.
This is what you do,
right Nancy,
what fucking guests?
What's the worst guests you ever had
that you just wanted to reach through
the screen and punched him in the face
and then she'd be telling a funny story
and then maybe,
and
that's it.
We'd be in,
you'd ask her about the Duke Duke
Lacrosse case,
whether it was she was unfairly accusing
them of something they didn't do.
I don't watch it on TV.
I don't watch the show,
but we are,
it's funny about her as she looks like
Ozzy Osborne in like 1985 during the
ultimate center.
Like when she wears the black eyeliner
sometimes I literally
a better looking Ozzie.
Of course.
Well,
I'm more dainty.
Ozzie.
Less Feminine.
More Bruce Jenner.
Ask less hard road.
Yes.
America in trouble.
The youth of today to day.
Yeah.
You know,
I saw something,
I don't know why this reminded me of,
Oh,
I think shaving down your Adam's apple
was,
I was thinking of,
I actually,
uh,
I don't know.
Sometime I started talking about torture
or some shit on my,
one of my podcasts and someone was
showing them the devices,
you know,
the rack,
the rack would,
they would,
they put him on,
they tie your legs and they would crank
it.
Okay.
And these guys did an experiment.
Was what gave way,
was that your tendons or whatever?
You know what it was?
They actually discovered it was the
bone.
Oh God.
Fucking broke or pulled away.
They they put like,
it was the creepiest thing ever where
they were just like,
this is a pig's ankle,
which is the closest to a human's ankle.
At which point you're sitting in home
gone.
Okay.
Like if they said it was a Yak,
like I would argue,
I have no idea.
So they put this thing on there and they
start,
they tied this little hook with part of
it's neat St.
It was just as much like the knee.
You got to see this thing and they start
cranking this thing and you're hearing
it every time it gave way.
You're heard a noise.
They would do an x ray and you know
these fucking scientists are so,
oh this is interesting.
This is interesting.
The patella is still there and the
issue,
see the middle car,
we'll fucking whatever the hell
ligament,
but what we're seeing is we're seeing is
stress in Nashville Femur,
which would be a femur and they fucking
kept doing it.
And what?
What gave way it was,
I guess I was the slowness of it that
made the bone break and not the fucking
tendons where if you just get hit quick
or something like that.
The tenants I,
you know,
I'm so fucking stupid.
I can't remember what they came
conclusion with,
but it actually broke your fucking
bounds.
It's amazing what inventions people came
up with just to fuck you up,
more like to make you more in pain while
there were killing you.
The two things that I've ever seen,
there's very few actually.
Maybe cats,
monkeys and human beings are the most
cats.
A mold breaking my bones,
the most sadistic like cats,
the way they catch a mouse and then fuck
fucking let the thing get away and then
get it again and give it hope and take
it away.
But you'd get the death penalty.
That's like somebody begging for their
fucking life.
Right?
Yeah.
I saw this video one time,
this chimpanzee like you know,
basic.
In the last 10 12 years they've
discovered that chimpanzees like the
occasional steak and want to eat another
monkey because they thought that they
were vegetarians.
So this fucking monkey trap,
this small,
it's chimpanzee trapped this smaller
one,
and he's basically standing on the
fucking thing up in a tree.
And rather than just snapping,
it's fucking neck.
It's taking its finger and his thumb and
just digging flesh out of its fucking
back and eating it as the monkey is
underneath that just screaming bloody
fucking murder.
And you just sit and I,
I've dude,
I fired a gun.
I would have blown.
That thing's fucking brains out.
Just start a principle.
I've seen that.
I've seen that video.
I've seen a bunch of those videos with
chimps.
They,
they liked to eat king hate chimpanzees
should the scary animals,
they are definitely should be respected,
but they like to eat the organs first.
They eat them while they're alive.
It's grabbed the,
apparently the Oregons the most
delicious part to them.
So while they're holding onto the
monkeys,
they're not trying to kill them first.
They're just trying to go right to the
guts and started eating.
Oh Dude,
it's just bending.
But getting back to you get back to the
rack,
like how could you,
the fucking agony you're putting
somebody through.
I couldn't do that.
I couldn't do that to somebody.
Don't you think it was?
That was during the time where first of
all people died like way,
way quicker.
Like people didn't live very long.
They live to be alert.
If you're lucky,
you got 50 years in holy Shit.
Like I lived to be 50 whilst the infant
mortality rate was really high.
There were constantly at war,
war was at close range.
So war involved like swords and arrows
and he thinks about shots.
The kind of fuck catalog does fucking
flaming bodies.
You know,
they used to literally light bodies on
fire because human fat is like a good
way of a lighting building's on fire
because it's so disgusting.
So when they would light us on fire,
they like human bodies on fire launch
them and catapults roofs.
Hilum first.
Yeah,
probably.
Maybe,
I don't know.
Whatever they wanted to do.
I can't Greenway to a tech center
lecture people.
Well,
when people get to that night you were
saying,
where are they?
Just going to use all the fucking fuel
to figure out a way to just have no
waste.
We use the waste and it becomes feel,
but that kind of life where you're,
you know,
your subject of violence and brutality
on a regular basis.
I bet they was that the movies where the
movies,
they only show the wars.
They don't just show it when they're
hanging out playing like a flute.
You know what?
I think there's probably a lot of war
going on pretty much all throughout
human history.
I just feel like you could hide so much
easier back in the woods.
Yeah.
He just ran into the woods.
That was the,
here I'm calming.
Ps,
you hear the floor fucking moving on the
horses back there.
You have to figure out a way to get away
from the wolves.
Yeah,
but you want going down to whole foods.
You a hunt,
your own food.
You were self sufficient.
Right.
But you had to have your bow and Arrow
and all that stuff.
You'd like to be close to town,
have a fucking blacksmith nearby.
Like when you're out there in the woods
by herself,
it's probably pretty,
pretty hard scrabble life.
Absolutely.
But you know something.
Anything that's going to kill it.
You kill it.
Kill you.
I was thinking shoot at you and kill
you.
Kill it.
You anything that's going to kill you
out there.
It's just,
it's going to be a quick like a dude.
If a mountain line ever fucking ran at
me,
I'd fucking just give him a neck.
Get it over with.
Dude.
I've gotten scratched by a fucking house
cat.
You think I want to fucking fuck with
you.
God Damn.
140 pound cat and proportionate like
they're there.
As far as like the strongest house cats
or the strongest cats,
it's house cats are with some of the
strongest pound for pound and mountain
lines like right up there with them.
Stronger even than like some other cats
that are terrifying to them.
How they fight off bears going into my
youtube video watching.
They definitely do.
It was doing all the animals shit.
Now is it an animal plant?
Is that what discovery just went all
cars like they don't fucking do anything
anymore.
Discovery.
Yeah.
Animals anymore.
Well there's a lot of shows like TLC
used to be the learning channel.
What do they do now?
Reality.
That's all reality.
It's I say history.
That's Tlc is honey booboo you don't
have with a history channel is they just
ran out of war footage.
They just raved.
Just got,
we got nothing.
And then they had to show like nothing
is interesting to anybody anymore unless
there's footage.
Like I hate it when they would do like
even like some of the civil war shit,
they would have to reenact it because
before remember when we were kids they
would just have drawings of it and they
would sort of pan the camera across
summit and which would put you to sleep.
And then World War II was the shit cause
they would just show him planes getting
shot down and all of that.
You know,
it was like a movie.
Well they had history channel had like a
lot of Nazi shows.
They had a bunch of those.
And then I think after a while they just
realize is more money in idiots.
This is more money and just reality TV.
It's just safe to a certain point in
time that you come in network.
Well,
I mean what I think happened was a bunch
of people will watch your reality and
Martin watching their shows and the rise
at the third hour,
right?
What happened in the night of the long
knives or whatever the fuck.
Then just no one cared anymore and
they're just like,
all right,
if that's what you want,
they have shit on like ancient aliens.
Like they have a,
I mean they have how many episodes of
ancient aliens have they done?
I totally believe in aliens,
but I don't think anybody has figured
out a way to travel from planet to
planet and actually live.
I think it's possible,
but I think that way too invested in it
being originally we could figure it out,
but we're going to destroy each other
first and I think everything kind of,
you destroy yourselves.
That's gods.
I think fucking checks and balances.
I made this thing smart enough to figure
out how to get over to this other pot of
people that I made,
but they got jealousy and envy and I
want credit and I want to produce your
credit on your fucking rocket ship and
all that shit and like they're all going
to destroy each other first.
Like we'll destroy it before we figure
even know how to get to fucking Mars on
it by a spell.
Where are you going to do,
first of all,
how do you,
how do you have enough air to get their
air?
Like in the oxygen?
Something that generates oxygen.
You'd have to have something to
processes.
Carbon dioxide generates oxygen.
There's a harder thing would be you
could,
you could probably do that a last,
so I guess the question is,
well,
plants do that,
right?
Is that what plants too?
But that's going to last all the way to
Mars.
Six months.
It's got to last six months and I
remember,
I don't think it takes six months to get
to Mars things.
Lots of sand.
I think they're saying it takes six
months.
No,
it doesn't.
I mean,
think about how far the moon is the
moon.
He just seven days,
you know,
all this shit.
No,
it takes six months to get the marks.
How long do you think it will take?
Fucking years?
No,
I'm pretty sure it's six months.
Let's see.
Uh,
how many months to get to Mars?
He's got a creepy tone right now.
I'm pretty sure it's six months.
I could be wrong
too.
I was very self deprecating.
It's possible,
um,
precise.
Six to eight months.
I think as far as an earth orbits are
perfectly circular.
But that's like just a drone though to
actually get a personal note for this is
a,
for a person,
this is for a person,
they're talking about the a man space
travel to Mars mission where they're
actually going to have to stay there,
which is really fucked up.
These people are gonna.
It's gonna take,
uh,
about six months to get there to do you
realize the fucking balls
that takes unbelievable.
I'm going to another fucking planet
forever.
And once you break the Earth's
gravitational pull,
what is stopping you from missing Mars
when that fucker comes around?
Talk to relations.
I know that,
but I'm saying if those things are off.
Yeah,
they never are though.
Jerry.
Speed up.
Speed up
towards fucking,
what's the next one?
Saturn.
Jupiter.
They're pretty good at figuring out
earth.
Mars,
Jupiter,
Saturn,
Neptune,
Uranus,
Pluto loop completed anymore.
They're bringing it back though,
right?
No.
Where'd you hear that?
I heard recently that they were
considering bringing it back as a
planet.
Did you hear that or read that on a
website?
This is how they should promote that.
They should have like when they bring
Pluto back,
they should have the scientists dressed
in like bell bottoms and shit with like
the,
the fucking Travolta thank you know like
they bring it back like disco
assumption.
No,
bringing it back.
Bringing it back.
Come on man.
I was dressed up like saludo.
No,
that's too on the fucking note too on
the nose.
You know what?
You know what I hate?
You know what I hate in a on a joke
writer room is they got a hat on a hat,
a hat on a hat.
When you have like a joke within a joke,
right?
Like it's like say say whatever the joke
is you fall off the fucking chair and
then you want to add another layer to
it.
They go that's,
that's a hat on a hat and it's just like
so what if it's still but they don't
understand like taglines.
If it's still funny.
It's funny.
Still is funny but if it's not funny
it's not funny.
No.
It's like if you had a half that's fine.
How come I can't look at the other
fucking hat the next time I watch it
cause I didn't even notice it.
If you have a hat on a hat and the hat
is funny,
it's funny.
That's what I think.
Yeah.
I think like they're acting like funny
plus funny equals not funny.
I think that does that.
How does that work?
I think that's just a lack of,
it's just the different mentality that a
comic has versus,
there's definitely like a place you can
go where it's not funny anymore or we've
had a too many jokes or you ruined the
original joke.
But I think a writers have a different
perspective and granted they write for a
living and I don't,
I just think their perspective is a
scene as opposed to your perspective,
which is like stand up,
you know,
looking at it standup wise.
No,
I'm not looking at it like this is going
to,
yeah,
I just think it's fucking funny.
I think as many layers as you can add to
it,
it just keeps getting funnier.
And then if people don't even get it,
that's fucking funny.
Like why would you even,
why would you fucking sit there and make
that damn rural?
I mean,
I guess,
you know,
I'm going against all of these
successful shows,
so whatever.
I just think there's a different style
of writing too.
Don't you think there's a different
style to way,
like you write for standup and the way
you write or you would write for a
television show?
It's,
it's just a different kind of writing.
I barely know what I'm talking about
ever.
So,
um,
I just,
maybe I'm just frustrated with pitching
jokes and then somebody's going to Ed.
That's a hat on a hat.
Like a hat on hat.
We'll see.
That's why I'm telling you a guy like
you,
your best shit is you just being you
without anybody that you have to pitch
it to.
Cause you know,
you have a very year from now when I
show up with the six episodes of
emphasis for funny,
I think you're getting up,
you're going to have you heard talking
about a cartoon.
I'm always 100% functioning too little.
My fucking,
she love it.
Animated,
whatever you call it.
It's
like if you look at like the most
innovative,
dangerous comedy on TV ever,
it's out park because they can get away
with those guys.
They've done the best social commentary
for like 17 years.
They don't get the credit they deserve.
Yeah.
Not even close.
They're animals.
They're the best.
They're and they're,
they're so innovative.
They're just constantly coming up with
new shit like every week.
Genius is that for their social
commentaries because how simplistic the
animation is that those guys that are
like,
but they can just churn them out but
like how finished and polished it is.
Yeah.
As a brand new joke coming right out of
the gate,
the first time they era where they just,
they just fucking nail it.
I think it's different.
For whatever reason.
I feel like they're going to have to do
it for 30 years and then tell people
that they're leaving before they're
finally going to just acknowledge,
you know,
they're going to get out the fucking
Mark Twain Award and all that stupid
shit that you supposed to get.
Well,
they get acknowledgement just by
everybody in loving them.
I mean the show is that they have taught
pretty much total autonomy over comedy
central.
They kind of get away with whatever they
want.
I mean they can,
they can pull off shit on their show
that no one could ever pull off on
another show.
Just don't think people give him enough
credit.
No,
I'm not going to change that argument
show.
I'm with you.
I don't think they give him enough
credit either,
but either way it's big.
They can do so much because it's a
cartoon and the characters never get
old.
They don't have to worry about their
character like Jj from good times.
That shit wouldn't have been funny if he
was 80 you know that their stuff is
dynamite.
We shut the fuck up.
Like what are you talking about?
No,
Jj from good times.
We're going to pull that one out of my,
well,
now that you brought up South Park,
I don't think it's going to be that
funny,
but I think it's going to be amusing
consuming music.
Show your show.
Yes.
What's it based on?
A childhood stories.
Oh,
your childhood stories?
Yeah.
Well basically everybody in the writer's
room at that point.
Oh,
so I just got sick of people groaning
about my childhood stories,
comedy.
I was like,
well,
what if I fucking animate them now?
What are you gonna grow?
Net.
Huh?
Wow.
That animated.
Yeah.
It's fucking annoying.
Why are you going to Indianapolis Bill?
No,
it's fucking annoying.
That shouldn't be a t shirt that you
sell.
I watched that,
that story that you told last time you
were on the podcast about the guy next
to you on the airplane.
I am questioning you work on
Indianapolis.
I watch that.
My paper for the most fun I ever had on
a flight when he said,
I'm going to push this button.
And as we're taxiing down,
um,
taxing over to where we're going to take
off.
And I was,
I was just,
Ah,
let's,
let's see what happens.
And he was sitting there reaching for
the pocket thing and I'm just sitting
there like,
let's see,
let's see what happens.
I had pushed the button.
So this,
um,
this animated show that you wrote,
who did you do it with?
Just do it all by yourself?
Or did you bring some money?
Uh,
Mike Price from the Simpsons.
Oh,
great.
Yeah,
it was just a fucking force.
And he put up,
he put together this murderer's row of
uh,
a writing room and um,
and then the produce a production
company is um,
um,
wild west,
which is Vince Vaughn's company.
And that's how the whole thing,
like I was just going to make a little
five minute vignettes and put them on my
website.
And then,
uh,
I don't know.
I don't want to happen.
I,
I I,
Steve Byrne,
I opened for him or something like that.
We were working together or some shit
and Vince was there,
saw my act wanting to see me,
uh,
hey,
come in and take a general and I had no
idea,
no idea is no nothing.
And it was really,
I just took a general like we like you
if you ever have anything,
you know,
ballpark general meeting.
Yeah,
general meeting.
Yeah.
And I was just walking out and as I
walked out I was like,
you know,
I kind of got this idea for a cartoon
and they wanted to do,
when they wait a minute and sit down and
three fucking years later we are one
year away from it coming out.
I mean,
it just works slowly,
slowly.
The,
the it,
what is the heart?
Nobody was,
didn't want,
nobody wanted the idea and everything
and the whole thing was dead in the
water.
And then Vince was the guy who was like,
let's go over to Netflix.
And even that guy's an ammo man.
He's in there in the fucking pitch
meeting,
selling this fucking thing.
And then Netflix was like ridiculously
supportive.
They're like,
you know,
do whatever you want.
Netflix,
shit further.
Push it further.
Yeah.
Do you see the ad for a Marco Polo,
Marco Polos,
a new series of the Netflix is doing on
Marco Polo and Gingiss cons,
like this huge fucking epic series that
they're doing.
So they have that orange is the new
black,
there's doing standup comedy specials,
like they're becoming like a real
legitimate network right before our
eyes.
There'll
be on that because they're international
and they are so ahead of the game that
all you're going to see is just people
trying to rip off their business model
is what's going to happen.
Uh,
you know,
it's the usual thing.
Like,
what are these guys don't know.
They're not going to fucking blah,
blah,
and all of a sudden,
okay,
all right.
And then,
then,
then the next thing you know,
you become the person and then
everybody's like,
oh,
that's the way you do it.
Monkey see monkey do.
And then I just think people will try to
rip off what they're going to do.
But they there at the,
uh,
you know,
they were on point,
so,
so they're cutting their way through the
jungle,
so there's still going to be out in
front of everybody.
So I think it's going to be very hard
for a,
I don't know,
maybe the fourth person who tries to rip
it off.
There might be room for two other people
to try to rip off what they're doing.
You know what I mean?
And then you have like three,
like ABC,
NBC,
CBS of International Television.
Well,
what they're doing that's unique is that
they're taking the money and they're
making their own shit.
That's the big thing there.
There've been doing it for,
I did my comedy special with them in
2005 that was originally on Netflix and
then it got sold to showtime,
but they were even back then,
I mean that's nine fucking years ago.
They were taking chances and funding
comedy specials and now they're doing
real originals that Kevin Spacey show
that um,
how's the cards,
you know they're doing and the horsemen,
yeah,
it's been killing it.
And your show,
they're doing a lot of Chelsea Peretti.
Her standup is on Netflix or a news
show.
Um,
I think,
um,
Chelsea handler doesn't she have like a
whole species?
Yeah,
she left her talk show as far as I know
on a e e to go do a talk show on
Netflix,
left the network to go to Netflix.
That's like,
that would not shoot.
I'm Alice speak for her,
but I don't think that moves gets made
two,
three years ago.
He shows you how quickly it changes.
Yeah.
It'd be like white men,
but I'm on,
I'm on television.
She's got so much fucking money though.
She probably doesn't give a fuck.
You know what I mean?
She,
she said make that much money on.
Yeah,
she's,
she's got a lot of money,
man.
She's a very,
well,
she's also,
it's not just that,
it's books.
She saw a lot of books,
you know,
she's in that stage to where she has
like this giant amount of fans that
could just follow her anywhere she goes
and I don't know how that works.
I don't get like,
how do you like,
uh,
how do you have a TV show and write a
fucking book?
I Dunno.
And do stand up in the constantly.
I mean she does.
She does a lot of shit.
She's just constantly working.
Yeah,
that's,
I mean I'm never going to be that busy.
I couldn't handle that.
Yeah.
I'm too busy right now.
I think there's a certain level of busy
where you just like,
you can coast,
you could like keep it,
keep the fire burning at a certain
temperature,
certain Rpms,
but it goes up and down when it goes.
I would think just having a TV show and
trying to keep that thing on the rails
and have just prevent someone from
coming in and fucking it up.
Would be,
uh,
would be hard enough.
That's a big thing.
Preventing someone from coming in and
fucking it up.
Right.
Cause that's a real issue.
Someone could definitely come in and
fuck it up.
Yeah.
Cause they want credit.
Yeah,
I got it.
They got,
you have to implement something that I
said again,
that's all negative shit.
I'm going to try to white whitewash all
that.
No,
not that it hasn't happened to me,
but I just,
I don't want to get a test.
It's our old fucking conversation that
uh,
everybody knows it.
That's,
that's what it,
that happens in every fucking business.
You know.
Look at the Geek squad.
That was a great thing.
And then best buy,
it was like,
oh hope dirge or make money without us
and then they fucking absorbed it and
nobody uses this shit anymore.
Squad before best buy.
It was just a bunch of nerds who would
fucking,
it's like Uber,
they said they would run around fixing
your computers and they dress like
nerds,
like with the black ties and the white
fucking,
and then bought them and then they
bought them.
And I've never seen it.
It was cool.
They showed up.
It was funny.
They were like embracing being nerds.
It's like 10 years ago they had the f I
haven't had fucking glasses and they
came over and they just fix your shit
and it kind of had like this spy vibe to
it.
Geek squad and they showed up dressed
like nerds,
but also kind of like a little pulp
fiction ESC except without the jacket
and it was a,
it was fucking cool.
I wasn't aware of them back then then.
Then they drove around in little
beetles.
Yeah.
Did.
Were you aware of him?
Oh yeah.
Before best buy bottom.
Yeah.
I wasn't using right now my fucking
laptop died.
What happened?
Do you use a Mac laptop?
Are you one of those guys that gets
frustrated?
Honestly,
I got frustrated and I slammed it shut.
Was it an apple laptop or a windows
laptop?
Apple.
See,
I would think of,
you might be one of those guys that
goes,
you know what,
I'm fucking sick.
All this apple shit.
Everybody uses apple.
I'm going to go windows and I'll see you
being hot guy.
Now.
What I do is I just,
uh,
I keep computers forever and I keep I
iPhones forever.
I'm always at least two numbers behind
whatever everybody else has.
Why do you do that?
Because when I say hello,
the person can hear me.
What does that mean?
It means it means I don't need a new
fucking phone.
Oh,
okay.
So it's firing.
He takes video.
I don't even need the gays and kneel at
this Gloria screen.
Look how beautiful.
Look how big that stupid ass fucking
thing is.
How dare you,
first of all,
how dare you.
Second of all,
the camera on this thing is fucking
substantially.
You got to see the new camera on the
iPhone six.
That's what I'm saying.
When I point that at my Dick,
dude,
you can see the helmets.
Great.
God Damn.
Picture a picture.
Joey Diaz.
That's great.
That's great God damn picture.
It's too clear.
It's fantastic.
We clearly look how good that is.
Huge.
Joey does not look like that in real
life.
Technology has gone beyond what you've
seen,
but young bill burr,
he does look like that.
He does look like that now I'm just,
you just see you're looking at them in a
little tiny 400 to talk you out of your
phone.
You obviously love it.
Could you make me feel bad about my
purchase?
I'm happy for you bill.
I remember like couple of years ago you
were still using mapquest.
Do you still use mapquest or do you
know?
I used,
I used the one that's on that,
that thing.
But the uh,
the one that's on your phone.
I mean,
you know what I hate.
I hate like the fucking recycled jokes
on the Internet and people like someone
would be like,
was this film with a potato for like the
9000000th time?
You're going to write that and be like,
can you just pick a different vegetable?
Can you try to elite a little bit
original?
I do not believe I've ever heard someone
ask you.
And I know you have home with a potato.
It's fucking,
it's like this recycled,
wait,
what?
Like those fucking
said no one ever.
It's like he's fucking like,
it's like mad libs.
That's true.
Said no one ever is pretty common.
But effective if used properly.
Like I reserve the right to you,
said no one ever.
If I'd fucking half too.
If it's right there,
I got to admit I,
I would,
I would definitely,
you'd a few notches I would drop off.
Seen watches in your estimation up
front.
I'm looking at drop a few matches the
stratosphere that I have.
You went right to build myself back up.
I have to fail a little.
Nah,
once you drop a certain point,
you dead to me.
I'll take that into consideration.
But wait what Wayne said,
no one ever within two hours.
If I got two of those tweets from you,
I would uh,
well when people say really stupid shit
like khaki comedy,
including all the people who now are
going to watch this and then tweet that
to me and they just think it's
absolutely fucking genius.
Not realized that like 9,000 people had
the exact same idea that water cooler
jokes.
You know those fucking just gay or you
know me.
You know about the Shit that Collin
Quinn makes fun of those fucking Collin
Quinn.
Yeah,
that it cause people don't even know
he's joking.
Like you know like one of the beautiful
things about knowing Collin and then
knowing his tweets is that some people
were reading his tweets and they might
not get it at all.
They might think,
do you remember the Colin Quinn show he
had on NBC?
He had one of the greatest fucking
sketches and it was like,
it was so much fun.
It was like office humor and I remember
Bobby Kelly's was the funniest one.
It was the high five guy at the office
in Bobby just comes walking by.
He just like,
dude got that new jet ski and he
fucking,
he just puts his hand up and you have to
high five fucking,
even the way you high five was
hilarious.
Mine was somehow I went up to Greer
Barnes,
not Greer Barnes.
I went up to Godfrey and and and said
some really white shit to him is Greer
Barnes was standing in delivering a
package like dude ain't took a
recommendation.
Something like God's for God's first
park was hilarious.
Some really stupid white movie.
And then Greer is sitting there looking
at God like he's a fucking sell on or
whatever.
I'm totally butchering this,
but it just totally tapped into like
when you work in those fucking offices,
the amount of like this like six jokes
and they all just keep telling them that
was in,
I'm not like those are the only jokes,
but there's like six jokes that you can
just always get count on
for a laugh.
What was that was on NBC,
right?
For how long?
Many episodes had called show last.
It was sort of the season,
right?
Only one season.
Like 600%.
And it was like we're liking it.
It was like what tough?
It was just on the wrong network.
It was what,
what tough crowd became.
Cause he also had this thing where uh,
Patrice and Norton and all of them will
be sitting down and just in different
areas it was actually shot really cool.
And uh,
they would just be talking about topics.
We had like a live thing.
He had these sketches thing.
It was a fucking great show.
It's a great show.
He's a funny dude,
man.
I want.
I did tough crowd.
I got to see him warm the crowd up,
you know,
he does stand up before it and I was
like,
I forgot how fucking funny kind of coin
this.
He's really fucking funny.
Really good.
The best was when he first got on
Twitter.
If you follow them early and nobody knew
what the fuck he was doing.
Are you doing gang signs over there?
I know I was doing three episodes.
Oh it only when he had,
when he first got on Twitter and,
and so many people didn't know what he
was doing.
It was fucking funny.
They still don't every day,
but he does still don't.
But he's like Zeplin such an underrated
band.
It's just a shame.
They never had a hit to that.
And people are like,
what the fuck is that?
All capitals.
But when you do that you're trolling
like dumb high school kids.
I think a lot of adults were fallen for
that too.
And uh,
when he would talk about how famous he
is and how,
who the fuck somebody stepped down in
[inaudible]?
I don't know.
He always,
he's always good for a fucking,
he's a funny fucking comic man.
Watching him do stand up like you really
get to appreciate it.
I think even live,
he's one of those guys you really want
to see a live like when you see him,
like even in film it's like you're
missing something.
You're missing half of the Canard.
Yeah.
He's amazing.
That show shit never been cancelled.
If they're smart they'd bring back.
Tough crowd.
Tough crowd was off.
Fucking great idea.
It was our great show.
You're speaking to that.
How weird is it?
There's two shows that have come back
that is the comeback came back with the
[inaudible] which was a great show was
just sort of ahead of its time.
But the weirdest fucking thing I ever
saw was when our cineo show came back.
Dude,
he came back with the same fucking
haircut,
maybe look 10 days older and then had
the same guests and it was just,
and it was like 20 years never went by.
It was,
it was like a,
it's a long,
one of the few times I ever wished that
I did like hallucinogens cause I was
just like,
this is,
it was blowing my mind.
It blew my fucking mind.
He had,
I think he had like Dyson or Eddie or,
or somebody and it was just like,
I felt like I was like 24 again and I
was just starting out as a comic when I
used to watch it going by,
if I get to do standup on this,
how am I going to,
how am I going to navigate?
Am I going to cross over to this crowd?
And
you know,
I dunno.
It was just bizarre.
They took over his social media accounts
when they did that show like East
Arsenio.
He's like,
because he was being too edgy.
No,
no.
That's what they do.
That's what they do now on a lot of
shows.
They demand to take over your social
media and they start tweeting for you.
How crazy is that?
That's what he told me.
That signing over power of attorney and
like an uh,
exact cyberspace kind of way.
Exactly like signing their name,
your name,
and he was trying to get his Facebook
back and it's Twitter back.
And I was like,
what?
He was telling me,
he was telling me this at the ice house
and I was like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
They made,
he goes,
I didn't want to initially,
but I said,
you know what?
I'm going to be so busy with the show.
Fuck it.
Let 'em do it.
Now I'm trying to get it back.
I'm like,
oh my God,
they just take over your account.
Yeah.
But if you let them,
you just say no.
Exactly.
No,
but you gotta be willing to say no.
It might be a deal breaker.
And he started Sineal go fuck yourself.
Yeah,
but came to me.
Yeah.
But they,
you know,
if they're thinking that people want to,
they want to be ball players,
you know,
hey,
we're willing to work with you.
Like
want to make this show it hit.
That's a Sioux thing.
They don't want to get sued by you
saying something fucking nuts.
And then Ima,
if you read the guys' interviews,
aren't seeing it was interviews are
always great because he doesn't give a
shit.
And he just Kinda says what he's saying.
So they're looking at like,
yes.
Says Wild Shit.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
I,
I know I just,
he's honest,
which does not work when you got to sell
toothpaste and fucking cars and all that
shit in between the comedy.
So I think that that's,
that's fine.
But having never gotten a show on the
air,
Joe,
this is what I feel is going on behind
the scenes.
We'll McGuire,
you know,
Chris Mcguire was the head writer,
uh,
on,
he was the head writer over there,
so he,
you know,
he told me it was a struggle from the
beginning,
but it was also that they were trying to
do the same show.
They're trying to do the exact same show
that they did in the 1990s,
which is really strange because I was
saying he was a likable guy.
I mean,
people love them,
but it seems like if you found the right
vehicle for him,
he'd be a great talk show host people.
He's genuinely friendly,
likable guy.
Yeah.
I mean,
like I said,
it was,
it looked like the exact same fucking
show and I felt like,
did I just like miss that this thing was
still going on and then he had all these
guests from back then.
I think that that,
like,
I think the whole thing could,
uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
I just want to just stop when I would
put it on when it first started.
Maybe just did that the first week.
Uh,
no,
no.
He kept doing it.
They kept doing it.
They,
they kind of does what they did.
I mean,
it might've altered a little bit,
but that was essentially the show.
It's hard to do those fucking shows,
man.
I could never,
I can have a host to talk shop.
No fucking way.
You don't get to choose your guests.
You know,
like people equate a podcast to a talk
show sometimes.
But the thing about a podcast is,
you know,
I,
I like you like I want,
I want her to talk to you today.
I tell you man,
like you man.
But you know what I'm saying?
Like I don't have to pretend.
It's like if you were some guy that I
didn't know that was in here that was
pitching something I didn't give a fuck
about,
but the network that my story is a dying
and then you got to save them.
Oh,
those are the worst.
Right.
And so on.
We'd have to jump in.
Well,
I,
I feel,
I feel bad for,
uh,
when,
when I see a talk show host and has a
guest where they're off or they're
their,
uh,
stories aren't working cause it,
you see him,
you see him like glancing down at the
card and then they got to like
letterman's the best thing they got to,
cause it'll just openly mock the
situation.
He'll just openly mock you if it goes
wrong like that.
I'll
just let you sit in it going,
okay.
Yeah.
Do you remember Bill Hicks bit on Leno?
Oh,
the Dorito thing?
Yeah.
The whole thing about having joy
Lawrence on the show and ask,
enjoy Lawrence if he has a girlfriend.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You know,
and,
and choices.
No,
well,
yes,
we'll shoot things.
So,
right.
He pulls a gun out of his drawer and
fucking blows his brains out and is his
brain splatter on the wall and the form
of an NBC peacock cause he's a company
man to the bitter end.
Jesus.
Dude,
that was word for word.
No,
I did.
I forgot all the part about him.
Uh,
changing clips.
He's,
he pulls out an Uzi and east suck on a
news and he's spraying bullets through
his head and he'd change his clips and
it's fucking hard gig.
Leno loves doing that show that he does
now because of that.
He does that car show online.
Jay's garage watch.
I go on that all the time.
I love it.
Great fucking car collection is insane.
It's insane.
And it's all like,
he's got great taste in cars.
Then he's got these fucking cars,
like those ones.
We got like two shifters and she's got
goggles on and stuff.
But,
um,
he had won a car recently,
that bank,
I crossed,
forget it.
I got obsessed with it.
If you want to look it up.
He did.
It was an early,
a seventies Dotson I think five,
10 and um,
they're just the coolest fucking cars.
If,
if you,
uh,
if you put like a new engine in the
suspension and everything cause it's
like,
it's like the classic American sustained
sedan,
but the miniature like uh,
Asian version of them.
And uh,
let's see.
Can you get a picture of it before I'd
just stammering a fucking complete black
hole here on this thing.
That's they just fucking bad ass car
man.
Oh.
So they did like a wretch stow,
a resto mod version of an old,
it's an old Datsun.
It's like a Datsun five 10 or something
like that doing,
it's got that little fucking,
the her shift or automatic,
it just looks so much fucking fun to
drive because my brother had a,
uh,
the smoothest shift in car ever drove.
He had like an 81 Toyota Tercel.
And when you changing gears in that
fucker,
they,
it just was like butter.
And it was this piece of shit and it
was,
I just couldn't understand that was that
that was a really bad time for American
cars where they would deliberately
making them to shit the bed.
It's 60,000 miles so you would get this
perpetual car payment.
At least that's the conspiracy theory of
it and all of these fucking uh,
Toyota cars that to remember that when
they started coming out in this,
but dominant only went up to 80 miles an
hour and everything that you,
the speed and not while the gas crisis
and all that,
and the Mustang became the Mustang to
became a car like Farrah Fawcett,
Provan Charlie's angels.
There was a such a hunk of shit.
It went from being one of the most bad
ass American muscle cars ever to a,
just a total plastic,
shitty shape,
ugly.
They made an ugly table within like five
to seven years.
It became just an absolute and all of
that.
There was so many of those held over
like a muscle car names that just became
like a shell of themselves,
like the Cougar and it become this big
fat ass fucking tutored like sedan,
like with sort of a poor man's like
Lincoln continental or something.
Um,
but whenever he,
but he is his collection of cars.
It's just fun.
It's fucking incredible.
And just his knowledge of them.
That's really cool.
Well,
he's really passionate about it.
That just shows you when you get a guy
doing something that he actually likes
to,
like Jay Leno
loves cars.
It becomes an amazing show when you have
him host the tonight show you like,
he doesn't give a fuck about Joey
Lawrence,
his TV show.
He doesn't.
Yeah.
So he's got it,
looked at it like he's,
he's trying to,
uh,
he's,
you know,
he's making some money and he's going to
go buy some cars now.
When I was a younger comic,
I used to judge them and belows fuck
bullshit.
You know,
back when I thought I was,
you know,
I should be wearing a leather jacket on
stage,
you know,
like I was saying.
And anything think,
but now that I've gotten older,
I'm like,
Nah,
fuck,
he's doing his show the way it wants to
do a show and then he wants to go buy
some cars.
Yeah,
he wanted to make some money.
Made some money.
Apparently does the word is always been
that he doesn't even spend his tonight
show money that he'd spends only a
standup comedy money.
That's where he gets all everything and
then the tonight show money,
I'll just went to the bank.
Can you imagine
dollar collapses,
poor bastard,
get all that money.
Like I don't understand having that all
in the bank when you're,
your account isn't shared up to like
fucking two,
300 grand.
Yeah,
it's not smart and then it's also it is
until it isn't,
well who knows what all in the bank
means though.
He might've investments,
he might've put it in bonds and mutuals
and all that
shit.
You got to convert it into cash,
gold stuff it in your fucking walls and
then just some of it in gold and they
just got to pray.
I haven't all of that fucking money and
trying to not,
who has that book you read when you were
in like fifth grade about the guy
catches the big fish and then he's
bringing it into this,
into inland and all those fish are taken
a bite out of it and by the end he's
just left with the skeleton.
That's what it's like having a ton of
fucking cash.
Everybody's just going to fucking
descend on you.
You know you're accounting bills all of
a sudden,
two plus two equals four is way much
fucking more difficult.
And they got to charge at $9 million
more for your fucking taxes.
Why?
Cause I have it.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
That's what they do and all of a sudden
everything becomes a big fucking
problem.
So you just advocate spending it all.
As soon as I advocate getting to a
certain level of success,
getting a machete in a pit bull and
sitting on your cash.
Yeah,
but right.
Laid out in the living room.
You just sit on a mound of it and you
order food,
have it delivered and have it delivered.
You never leave.
He'll bills off the pile of pay for.
I have no,
uh,
my,
whatever in society.
Is Society going to Shit My,
uh,
my plan is I just embraced the fact that
you can only kill me once.
That's it.
I'm going,
I'm,
I'm not going to survive that
you hope.
But what if it's like groundhog day?
Keep dying like that new Tom Cruise
movie.
The edge of tomorrow we dies over and
over.
Spoiler alert.
Well then I would just get a gun and
then
how would just walk around like this and
I wait for the awful death to come and
then I go like that.
I like how you thought this through over
may a lot of really good points.
You know,
I learned it buying it.
Buying an old house.
Yeah.
Oh,
you going to be the guy who lays in a
shallow grave and waits for people to
attack
you food supply.
Then you sit up like a Zombie.
Me Know.
I'll be more clever than that.
I'll probably set up a fake civilization
and then be outside of that civilization
and the real civilization like,
so people come in to raid and then
fucking launched down on him.
He's,
he just words fire what I'm saying.
Listen,
I,
I've planned this out.
No.
If,
if the shit hits the fan,
I hope the,
um,
where the fan explodes.
That's what I think too.
Like if yellow stone blows and we wind
up living in some sort of a perpetual
nuclear winter for the next hundred
years,
I hope the lava lands on my fucking
head.
I don't,
I don't want to be one of those
absolutely.
Hardscrabble people out there in
Antarctica trying to eat seals and stay
alive.
Help reinvent the wheel.
No,
I don't find that.
I cause what you're gonna do then what
are you going to do?
Yeah.
That's like
realization went through a divorce right
in there.
The guy that gets like the flop house,
you know what I mean?
Like you're just,
you're just going to,
you're never going to build it back up
in your lifetime.
So why not leave with a flat screen TV
watching MMA shit,
whatever you want to fucking watch.
And then the ice still a bit about that.
Just when that Korean debt,
little fatty,
they're over in Korea was talking about
how he's going to shoot a fucking
warhead.
And I was nervous until he said la and I
was like,
perfect dude,
right at my fucking giant forehead.
I don't even want,
I don't even want to know.
Just hear that whistling sound like what
is that?
Somebody watching bugs bunny.
What does that whistling sound?
And then it just fuck it lands right on
my house and then that's it.
Yeah,
you don't want to be the guy who's
barely survives and has kids and then
dies where your kids are like standing
over you and they're eight and you know
they can't live on their own.
You're,
you're fucking,
you're dying in front of their eyes.
Like you don't want to be that guy and
you don't.
You also have to take into consideration
that even if the human race survives,
eventually it won't,
whether it's a million or a billion
years from now,
eventually the earth will no longer be
able to sustain life because the sun
will burn out.
So like,
well,
it's not going to last forever.
I'm just talking about like our
lifetime.
If some bullshit happens,
I don't want to go back to them to the
world where like boils and shit and
warts on the end of your nose or an
issue now because there's no more cvs is
and shit,
whatever the Benadryl,
a crap you'd put on it and then
everybody starts looking like a,
which I like.
They live under a fucking bridge.
Do you know that it's ever gotten a
warrant?
Other nodes know what I'm saying?
It'll back in the day.
So cvs keeps us from getting warts in
the nose.
That's another
did I'll take out of the universe is
gone,
compound w is gone,
dollar collapses and all of that Shit.
Everything stops being made.
It's done.
They're your best bet is you can fucking
go down to cvs and you rate all those
drugs.
That's what you do when you take some
bread and you leave.
Right.
And you just start pouring them in
between sets
and you fucking eat them like a captain
crunch sandwich and all the drugs in
breakfast club.
Yeah,
I don't think that's a good idea either.
None of them is a good idea.
Nobody has a good idea.
The only people who are okay,
it would be if you joined blackwater
where they actually have like a
fortress.
They're the ones who are really ready.
My favorite ones,
when you watch those doomsday preppers
and they're basically reading through
their playbook,
that's all.
I had that shallow grave like this guy
was.
What I'm gonna do is I'm going to
surrender my property and let them
infiltrate it and then I'll fucking come
around and he's like showing like where
he's going to hide and then I'm going to
be on a spring,
like one of those Murphy beds.
He rises up
the craftmatic craftmatic you bring your
legs engine slow.
You want to be on one of those Murphy
beds where it pops up.
Oh,
you faking dead.
So they don't see you in the background.
It's just slowly,
slowly coming up.
He is pointing.
Well,
you know those beds,
you push them the three stooges bed.
Yeah.
People get stuck in them and they get
pinned against the wall mart.
They're called Murphy beds.
Right.
You know they used to eat.
That was a popular thing to save space.
Laverne and Shirley.
Oh,
those things would fucking people get
stabbed him.
You probably break your fucking,
I bet somebody broke their fucking neck
and one of those.
I bet.
I bet people have died the most bizarre
ways.
Yeah,
I dunno.
Listen Buddy,
it's almost a quarter to four.
You got to get out of here.
Yeah.
What are you going?
I'm going to Hawaii.
Why Nolan?
Home Bill.
I'm going to,
I'm going to beat the traffic.
Where are you going to Indianapolis,
Bill.
Try to beat the traffic.
Try to eat healthy.
So come down and do your shelter night.
All right,
so bill burr will be at the comedy store
tonight.
Bill burst special will be on Netflix
this Friday,
December 5th.
What's it called again?
I'm sorry.
You feel that way.
The fucking,
the previews look awesome.
And I liked the fact that he did it in
black and white.
You silly bitch,
you going old school.
Next one you should do with smoke
signals.
It's just no,
no more,
no more film.
I don't,
I don't like HDTV.
Just don't like,
it's too fucking clear.
You don't need it.
You can do whatever the fuck you want.
It's your already already know how.
I'm going to film the next one too and
you will tell me once this is over
probably uh,
in your own little passive aggressive
way and with the iPhone six make fun out
to,
those are the latest fucking cameras
that I use.
By the way,
the iPhone six cameras for the is a
stylized,
oh,
okay.
This is not three stooges,
black or white.
And resent the fact that I've been on
this podcast for an hour and 45 minutes
and you would do that to me.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm sure I'll love it.
I'm a fan.
I'm a bill burr fan.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I don't believe a word of it.
All right.
Thank you for having me.
I L L B U R,
or thanks for being here,
man.
Anytime you want.
Come on back.
Thank you for having me.
And I will see you eight 30 tonight at
the comedy store.
Yes,
my friend.
That's right.
The hilarious bill.
Barley's German.
All right.
Uh,
we'll be back next week until then.
Go fuck yourself and give everybody see
for real.
Go.
Go buy it.
I've been watching bill work this
material out.
I saw you at the Ice House recently.
Fucking hilarious.
Set.
So funny,
funny,
funny dude.
So that's it folks.
See you soon.
Bye.
Big Kiss.
Yeah.